Please join me in welcoming Patrice
[inaudible].
Hi,
Google Seattle.
I live lively audiences,
so please feel free to and I amen.
Um,
this is the introduction to the book.
We are stardust days.
After the election of 2016 Asha sent me a link to talk by Afro Physicist Neil
Degrasse Tyson.
We have to have hope.
She says to me across 3000 miles,
she and Brooklyn,
me and Los Angeles,
we listened together as degrasse Tyson explains that the very atoms and
molecules and our bodies are traceable to the crucibles and the centers of stars
that once upon a time exploded into get gas clouds and those got gas clouds
formed other stars and those stars possessed the divine right mix of properties
needed to create not only planets,
including our own,
but also people including us,
me and her.
He is saying that not only are we in the universe,
but that the universe is in us.
He is saying that we human beings are literally made out of startups.
And I know what I hear degrasse Tyson say this,
that he is telling the truth because I've seen it since I was a child.
The magic,
the stardust,
we are on the lives of people I come from.
I watched it and the Labor of my mother,
a Jehovah's Witness and a woman who worked two and sometimes three jobs at a
time,
keeping other people's children,
working the reception desks at gyms,
telemarketing,
doing anything and everything for 16 hours a day.
The whole of my childhood and the Van Nuys Body or where we lived,
my mother,
Cocoa Brown and smooth.
This is owned by her family for the children she had.
She had as a very young and unmarried woman.
My mother never gave up despite never making a living wage.
I saw it and the thin brown face of my father,
a boy out of Cajun country,
a wounded healer who's addictions were born of a world that did not love him and
told him so.
Not once,
but constantly.
My father who always came back,
who never stopped trying to be a better version of himself.
There were no mirrors for,
and I knew it because I am the 13th generation progeny of the people who survive
the holes of slave ships,
survived the chains,
the whips,
the months laying in their own shit and piss the human beings legislator.
That's not human beings who watched their names,
their languages,
their goddesses,
and Gods,
the arc of their dances and beats of their songs,
The majesty of their dreams,
their families snatched up and stolen,
disassembled and discarded.
And despite this built language and honored God and create a movement and upheld
love,
what could they be?
But start us,
these people who refuse to die,
who refuse to accept the idea that their lives did not matter,
that their children's lives.
This did not matter.
Well,
first I need to start my thinking you.
Um,
it's for me in particular.
I will be,
I will start with a personal note of that.
That's very meaningful as a queer woman of color,
as an immigrant,
as I mentioned to you,
this for me is,
it's a big honor,
so I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually want to talk a little bit about,
um,
you start by the story by history,
talking about your family,
um,
in particular in your mom and your brother and your father,
and you focus a lot on this idea of collective responsibility versus personal
responsibility.
Um,
so I'd actually ask you to talk a little bit more about that.
Why do you believe that this focus that we have on personal responsibility,
it can be so detrimental,
particularly the black individuals?
And what is there to gain from moving to this idea of collectivity?
That's a great question.
Um,
I,
because I was literally just talking to a reporter about this,
um,
when I got off the plane,
which is,
um,
for many of us who grew up in poor neighborhoods who grew up in poverty,
the experience we had,
what was it was our fault.
We were blamed for our family,
unable our families being unable to feed us.
We are blamed for our families addictions.
We are blamed for,
uh,
the states coming after our family.
We were blamed for so many things that had everything to do with a system that
is literally created to harm and decimate communities.
And so the question becomes who is accountable?
Um,
is it the people who are both of the margins,
the people who have experienced some of the most suffering?
Or is it a system?
Uh,
is it local government?
Is it state government?
Is it federal government?
Um,
uh,
and as we live in under this current administration,
um,
how do we hold it accountable?
How do we hold local government accountable to actually produce,
um,
laws that will support human beings,
produce policies that will support human beings?
Um,
and how do we,
um,
challenged the idea that a young mother who,
had a child at 16 deserves to be kicked out of her home,
deserves to not receive the type of support and aid just because she had
children out of wedlock or just because she had a child at a young age?
I mean,
these are the kinds of questions that we need to ask ourselves.
And I think what happens,
because we live in a culture and an America in particular that really values
personal respondent's responsibility really values the idea of pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps.
Um,
well that only actually works for certain people.
and the pulling up by your bootstraps,
um,
is designed for certain people and not designed for others.
And when we can have an honest conversation about the design,
then we can have an honest conversation what it should look like,
um,
how it should look differently.
And so,
um,
not only am I challenging the idea of personal responsibility,
which I,
which I think is different than asking people to be accountable.
I want to like differentiate,
differentiate those terms.
Um,
someone being responsible,
um,
for,
their own poverty.
Um,
no,
but someone being accountable,
being accountable to their family,
right.
My mother was accountable to us cause she worked 16 hours a day.
Um,
but she wasn't responsible for her poverty.
And I think we have to be able to differentiate that.
And the last thing I'll say on this is,
um,
it,
well it will take all of us at has to be all of us to change the system,
to change this place to collectively come together and make a decision as many
of us say.
And black lives matter.
When black people get free,
everybody else gets a little bit more free.
Um,
on the,
on the black lives matter movement in particular,
the,
the shooting of Trayvon Martin and the acquittal of if his shooter,
it's clearly a bit unimportant moment in that movement.
Um,
can you speak a little bit as to why that,
that moment,
uh,
resonated with you so powerfully when it did?
Yes.
And the,
and what you're going to notice is I'm always going to kind of take a few steps
back because the moment is the moment,
but there's some,
there's things that lead up to the moment that actually makes that moment,
the moment.
So for me,
um,
it was,
uh,
I come from a generation,
I'm born in 83 and so I come from a generation that,
uh,
witnessed,
um,
Reagan,
witnessed,
um,
the bushes,
witnessed the Clintons and,
and those presidencies,
what we got to see was a ratcheting up of the war on drugs are ratcheting up of
mass incarceration,
um,
and ratcheting up mass criminalization of very particular communities,
black communities in particular.
Uh,
and as I grew up,
um,
and as many of us grow up in this job and this particular era and age group,
we're the word sort of the sacrificed ones where the children who are being
impacted by deindustrialization with children who are being impacted by the
militarized policing.
And so once we get to Trayvon Martin,
so many things have happened.
92,
Rodney King Oscar grant has happened.
And then Trayvon,
although not killed by law enforcement,
he's killed by vigilante,
who's empowered by state,
that empowers law enforcement.
And so,
um,
I didn't think that George Zimmerman was going to get off then.
I was like,
you killed Trayvon Martin.
We all knew that.
Jerry knew that I didn't think he was gonna get murdered,
but I definitely didn't think he was gonna get to go home.
And when he did on July 13th of 2013,
I was very clear that that wasn't going to be the period to the story,
um,
that we had to do more,
that I had to do more personally.
And as I heard Sabrina Fulton Trayvon's Martin's mother specifically speak out,
um,
uh,
through tears,
through grief and call on the people of this country,
um,
to show up for her child to show up for her.
Um,
I just felt like it was incredibly important.
And so I,
I was on social media,
like many of us are,
um,
angry and upset and trying to figure out how to understand what was happening.
And I came across a good friends' Facebook posts,
Alicia Garza,
and she wrote black lives matter.
And then I put a Hashtag on it and Alicia was like,
what's the Hashtag?
And I was like,
it's this thing that can go viral.
Um,
but I'm also a trained organizer,
so I didn't just,
I wasn't just interested in an online campaign.
Um,
I was interested in how we translated black lives matter to the ground and how
it really could be a grassroots movement that can bubble up,
change the world,
change the country.
And on July 15th,
when we solidified black lives matter is a political project I wrote on social
media again,
I said,
hey,
Alicia and I have started this project called black lives matter.
And we hope that it will impact more than we can ever imagine.
One of the things that you talk about a lot in your book is taking that Hashtag
you say that I think Hashtag [inaudible] movement.
So essentially creating power under this umbrella of black lives matter.
What has that journey been like?
What are some of the lessons you've learned?
Challenges,
victories.
Well,
we have to remember that black lives matter really started organically.
It started online,
it's organic moment and it was very quickly,
um,
galvanized into a political project.
Really.
Those,
that first year was nurturing it.
Having people talk about black lives matter and the organization's at their
offices.
Um,
having,
um,
a lot of like conference calls,
that's how do we use this,
taking it onto the streets during protests.
Uh,
but I would say that the heights of a BLM or where it becomes,
um,
worldwide is after the non indictment of Darrel Wilson.
And,
uh,
after Mike Brown's killer is not indicted,
that is the first time it goes viral on social media.
And I remember being like,
we have to do more.
Um,
we have to figure out what's the next step,
what's the next angle?
And,
um,
600 of us went and did a black lives matter freedom ride.
And we drove into Saint Louis.
And before we drove in,
we called folks,
you know,
uh,
folks let us know what we could come in and we're not just showing up to
people's neighborhoods.
And,
um,
and that,
uh,
on that three day journey,
because it was only three days,
uh,
there was two commitments we made.
The first commitment was a show up for the people of Saint Louis.
Um,
to let them know that we're not going to allow for,
um,
Ferguson PD and every other municipality,
uh,
law enforcement is fatality to treat this community this way without us
watching,
witnessing and going back and telling our communities.
But the second thing that we said,
um,
that,
uh,
we wanted to make sure we did as go back home and organize and build what we
would then build,
which is the black lives matter global network,
which is an organization of 40 chapters around the globe here in the u s and
Canada and the United Kingdom.
One of the things that you discussed on the black lives matter in particular is
this idea of creating a Hashtag that people would be able would embrace.
And the word black ends up being sort of a big point of salient when it comes to
it.
And more.
I think more recently in the tech community we've had,
um,
one of diversity eat or say that if you have 12,
I think it's white,
blue eyed man in a room.
It's a diverse room because people have different ideas.
So I wanted you to speak a little bit about intersectionality,
which is such a big part of your book,
but also how do we have a genuine conversation about intersectionality,
um,
without it becoming an all lives matter conversation?
Like how do we actually bring that in a way that is genuine,
right?
How do you have a conversation and practice about intersectionality without
white washing it?
Yes.
Cause that can happen.
And um,
what,
what is important as we understand where words come from and that words,
what's been really interesting about this administration as they basically made
words,
um,
uh,
what's the word?
Meaningless.
You could say,
I hate all Edwards.
And then the next breath you could say,
I'm not a racist.
That doesn't even make sense.
Right?
But becomes an argument not just in media,
but it also becomes the argument and people's relationships and friendships and
all that guy said,
I could say this,
it's still not be a racist.
Um,
and I think,
uh,
with enter the word intersectionality really comes from a woman named Kimberly
Crenshaw.
And she created it because she was trying to challenge the conversation
specifically in the black community,
um,
that the only people who have the right to talk about,
black folks freedom is cis black men.
And she was really trying to challenge the idea that,
um,
if we're,
if we are going to fight on behalf of black,
black people,
we have to fight on behalf of black girls and women as well.
Um,
and that there is a very specific type of experience that black women have and
relationship to race.
And that Patriarchy is a part of racism when it comes to black women.
And that if we don't have those conversations,
but more importantly,
if we don't practice differently,
we're going to just end up in the very same cycle that we've been in and not
gaining the things that we really want to gain.
So it's important I,
if you value,
uh,
the lives of people,
um,
this is a conversation about what we value.
If we value that certain people's lives need to be prioritized because we've
seen that be de prioritize.
If we value that human,
all human beings deserve to be treated well with dignity,
with care,
um,
then we're going to be able to have more nuanced conversations about not just
black lives matter,
but means to women's march time's up.
I mean all the immigrants rights movement,
all these movements are in relationship to one another.
And I think it's important,
um,
that we sometimes we get caught up and the rhetoric of politics.
Um,
and I like to,
to reel it back a bit and remind people of values,
what are our values and,
and that,
um,
is often the place where it opens up something new for people to have a
different type of conversation about these things that often can feel very
challenging to talk about
on the,
on the issue of black women in particular,
um,
the,
with the election of Trump and is one of the things you mentioned your book is
that you felt particularly powerless because 95 96% of black women didn't vote
for Trump.
Um,
and with the Jones' election,
this idea that black women essentially like saved,
um,
the state of Alabama,
means
do you think that this is a pivotal moment of,
of looking at black women as a part of electoral power?
Or do you think that they sort of just as a passing concern now since we had
these consecutive elections or the numbers were so stark?
I think,
you know,
in a lot of ways black women historically have always been at the helm of
movements.
We've always been at the sort of intersection of both trying to save our
families and save the world.
And um,
what we're seeing and what we saw with the election of 45 and with the election
of,
um,
the,
the getting Roy Moore not into office is black women galvanizing power and being
strategic about it.
You know,
I think there was a big fight because people were like,
well,
why did you go for Jones?
And people were [inaudible] and folks had to counter that and say,
actually,
this was strategic.
You know,
this is the other person that was running and we need to make sure we didn't
have this other person and charge.
So this idea,
um,
I think after that happens that black people just sort of like naturally do
these things are we don't have a plan and there's no strategy or it's all
organic.
Um,
sometimes those things are true,
but oftentimes people have a strategy like Rosa parks.
It's very upsetting that people think that Rosa parks just sat down on a chair
and then some white guy came over and she was like,
I'm not going to get up today.
It's not how it happened.
Y'All,
there was a strategy behind the,
and she was a strategist.
I mean she was one of our most brilliant strategists and we don't hear that very
often.
We don't,
we don't get that story,
get this very ageist,
weird like feminizing story of how she just happened to be too old and tired to
get up.
Um,
rather than they sat and rooms trying to figure out how are they going to
boycott this system that literally got most,
almost all the black populations to work.
And to school,
how do you convince black people to not get on a bus that can jeopardize their
jobs and their,
and their schooling.
And that moment with Rosa parks,
not getting up is just the moment.
But there was all these other moments before that got us there.
And so I just,
I think that's important because,
um,
I,
part of what the book is trying to do is also really let people know that
there's a strategy.
And so much of the time that we,
that black lives matter has been developing.
There has been all this criticism,
well what,
what's the,
what are you all really what,
what are your goals?
Um,
and this book is trying to lay the record straight.
So I,
um,
I want to make sure that we have a lot of time for questions from the floor.
So I have one last question I wanted make sure I ask you.
Um,
and then we'll open up.
So she want to start lining on the microphone and we'll do that.
Um,
question.
One of the things that I,
uh,
that is,
a theme that you draw for the entirety of the book is this idea of your
community and you're always pulling people.
And I think one of the things that you said that I thought it was very powerful
is that they wouldn't let me be erased.
That will never let them be race.
Um,
can you speak a little bit as to why black community in particular is so
important to you?
Like what is it about your community that you feel is,
is necessary?
Um,
and,
and sort of the world we're living in today?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think this is a simple answer,
which is I grew up around some of the most brilliant and talented and powerful
people,
my siblings,
my parents.
And yet,
um,
they receive a very,
very little support for their gifts,
their talents.
And that is solely based off of race and racism and classism.
And so,
um,
to witness that,
I also ended up,
and I talk about this in the book is I ended up being sort of plucked from my
elementary school and labeled as gifted.
And so I go to a separate,
totally separate system than my siblings do,
which what,
which happens to make me see how other people live.
Um,
cause you don't know how other people live unless you go see it.
and in that experience,
you know,
going from my own neighborhood,
which was a small suburb outside of the inner city of Los Angeles,
that was mostly poor working class.
I'm surrounded by white suburb and that's where I ended up going to school.
I got to see firsthand just how classes in plays out,
just how racism plays out and that just based off of your,
um,
socio economic background or your race that your entire life changes.
Um,
and what's predicted for you.
And so,
you know,
I always say my mother would be like the most amazing therapist.
She's like the person who I learned how to have important,
courageous conversations from.
Um,
and yet she was relegated to menial jobs,
um,
because she never got,
uh,
um,
middle school diploma,
high school diploma.
And so there's these things that,
these barriers that exist for poor folks that are solely because people don't
have money.
And I think for,
for the community I grew up in black communities in particular,
um,
there's this longing that I have for us to be fully seen and fully realized
because I know what gifts we have
black lives matter and do with the fact that people rightly or wrongly get very
antagonized
the opposite,
right?
And a lot of different ways it depends on the audience,
depends on the person.
Um,
you know,
some days I choose not to even answer those questions.
Um,
just for my own sanity because the reality is,
and for folks who are in the room who are clear on the fence around all lives
matter,
black lives matter,
all lives do better.
Um,
that's actually not the argument right now.
and black lives matter is really just black lives matter too.
And so black lives matter is not about exclusion.
It's about focusing and does it.
A community who has spent 500 years in this country get to decide how we focus
our energy and aren't we allowed to ask people allies to join us in this fight?
Um,
and I think,
um,
what I try to do in those conversations is really challenged people.
Um,
sometimes gently,
sometimes not so gently about what kind of world do you want to live in?
Do you want to live in a world where,
where,
where the state is allowed to execute people and get away with it?
Do you want to live in a world where someone can get stopped for a broken tail
light ended up in jail and then not survive it?
Do you want to live in a world where people only because they don't have
physical papers are allowed to be ripped from their families and deported back
to their so called countries?
What kind of world do we want to live in?
That's what black lives matter is asking us.
It's asking us to think about the world we want to live in.
And,
okay,
if you want to live in a world,
um,
where terrible things happen to human beings,
then maybe I shouldn't be talking to you about this.
So my question is,
aside from your work,
what's one piece of literature or art or entertainment that right now in this
moment that we're in really gives you hope for the future?
That's a good one.
Um,
well I really love Octavia Butler.
Other people in the audience.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Um,
uh,
although it's kind of sinister,
sometimes morbid,
um,
she opens up a portal around how to have really hard conversations about race
and class and gender,
um,
and this most at some of the most beautiful and courageous and innovative ways,
and,
and more pop culture.
I definitely think the work that Issa Rae's doing and Lena Awakens doing in
particular,
um,
it's very exciting and powerful and fresh and innovative.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I got for you.
So thank you again for coming.
Um,
I understand that you were awarded a peace prize.
Hello.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
So
congratulations.
Can you talk a little bit about,
um,
what you've seen in,
in how the movement has been received outside the u s versus inside the US?
Yeah.
You always liked something better when it's outside.
Um,
the black lives matter global network received the Sydney Peace Prize last year.
very amazing.
I had no idea what it was before I received it.
And when we received it,
I looked it up and I was like,
oh,
this is a very big deal.
And,
um,
folks like Naomi Klein,
I've received it.
That's when two,
two has received it and I'm Chomsky's received it.
Uh,
and I think we were that literally the youngest people who've ever received the
Sydney peace prize.
Um,
and we were,
um,
not only welcomed by the country of Australia,
we were welcomed by black folks in Australia,
aboriginal populations,
first nations people.
Um,
and also really welcomed by the media.
I mean it was very,
very different experience.
Um,
then the type of experience we've had here,
um,
starting black lives matter.
And I think it also challenged this idea of us being a terrorist group or
organization.
Um,
because someone wrote about it,
they're like,
black lives matter,
just want a peace prize.
You could stop calling him a terrorist organization.
Um,
but it was,
uh,
it's been very powerful,
um,
to
the folks of Australia.
We're looking to us,
um,
around how they deal with race and racism in their country.
Um,
and um,
how to really have a new type of movements,
um,
that that's hopefully going to bubble up there.
Uh,
and that was,
um,
more,
more than inspiring,
more than I could ever have imagined.
Um,
and I'm very grateful that our network was honored with the,
um,
the peace prize,
but actually want to follow up on the term terrorist.
Yeah.
Cause it's a term that is very important in your book and the title when they
call.
Exactly.
That's how you know it's important.
Can you speak a little bit as to why that word has so much power?
Well,
um,
raise your hand if you or people in your community I've ever been called a
terrorist or Shanghai.
Now look around.
Right?
Um,
so the first time black lives matter is called a terrorist organization.
There's two things that come up for me.
The first one is,
um,
devastation.
Um,
because simply I'm with these folks every single day.
I know exactly what we're doing.
I know what type of sacrifice where giving.
Um,
the other is,
um,
a sense of serious fear because the moment the government starts calling people
terrorists,
that means there's going to be a war on the people.
And so,
um,
I think what's important in this book and the conversation I was trying to have
is what do we mean when we,
when we mean terrorist and who ends up being labeled as such?
And what we've seen for especially for black people in this country is whenever
we decide that we're going to fight for our freedom,
that we're going to fight for our dignity,
for,
um,
uh,
we're going to fight for our humanity.
That there's a label that's slapped on us or a community to undermine our
efforts,
but also to criminalize our efforts.
And so,
um,
what we've seen in,
and I'll just ask another question of the audience.
How many of you have heard of the black identity extremist label?
Yeah.
Who made that up?
What,
yeah,
FBI,
it was probably Jeff session,
I'll be with the FBI.
He's definitely defending that identity,
an identity that was literally crafted and created by the FBI and the UN and
many of us saw it and a leaked report,
um,
that,
uh,
that came out in August,
2017 and the report literally is claiming that black activists have a new
identity in which we are more violent towards law enforcement.
Um,
and for many of us that have studied movements or have elders in the movement,
like Angela Davis,
Ericka Huggins,
um,
in our conversations with them,
they're like,
yeah,
this is the beginning of what it looks like to be criminalized by the state for
your activism.
Um,
similar to what cointelpro did.
And so the terrorist conversation is,
I'm interrogating this idea that black activists,
people who are literally trying to fight for American democracy are terrorists.
And yet the people who are trying to change and reform are terrorizing our
communities.
Um,
and,
and how much we have to be,
um,
challenging those terms,
challenging that language,
um,
and showing up differently,
I think in this moment.
What is different from 30,
40 years ago is there were no elected officials trying to fight for the Panther
party.
Um,
now given the,
given what we know about cointelpro,
given that we know that they assassinated people rip families apart and ripped a
really powerful movement apart.
Um,
there are,
um,
elected officials,
specifically the congressional black caucus that is standing up to the FBI
around this term and congressmen,
woman,
Karen Bass has been leading the crusade around that.
Or a couple of questions.
You talked a little bit about the [inaudible] of the black lives matter Hashtag.
Yeah.
Um,
and so I guess I'm interested in,
so like in recent times Trump has kind of taken over news and like you hear a
lot about white supremacy and you hear a lot about these other things that kind
of stuck up all of the media attention.
Yeah.
And I'm wondering like,
to what extent do you think it's important for black life matter to have that
viral aspect and like what,
what,
what do you think are like,
what's the future of the black lives matter movement,
um,
in a,
in an environment where it becomes more difficult to have a voice?
That's great.
That's a great question.
Well,
what I will say is,
um,
sometimes in movements you need to be a little bit more quiet.
Um,
being out there all the time makes you vulnerable and,
and it's made us vulnerable and sometimes that's not always for the best.
So I'm going viral is not the goal necessarily.
Um,
it has a great outcome.
I think the better question is how do you sustain us?
How do we sustain ourselves?
Um,
and especially as we are building out a global network,
how do we create an infrastructure on institution power that can challenge and
power a challenge?
The current Hauer structure.
That's what we're most interested in this moment.
We're interested in the long haul.
Um,
and uh,
I I think,
I think we're onto something.
Um,
and I think we are developing a new type of experiment experiment,
um,
that is centering black folks in particular.
Hello.
Thank you for speaking to us today.
You are amazing.
I don't think,
um,
I want to ask you a question about how you think capitalism and um,
large capitalist in the CS,
uh,
such as Google may affect black lives matter either positively or negatively.
Um,
such a good question.
Well,
what I will say,
uh,
is,
um,
living in this current infrastructure that we live in that is a capitalist
infrastructure is not sustainable for anybody.
Um,
and as the rich literally get richer and the poor literally get poorer,
um,
we have to have a longterm solution or I'm not only how we're going to save
human beings,
but how we're going to save the planet.
And we unfortunately have an administration that doesn't believe in climate
change.
It like drives me nuts.
Y'All were literally burning up in some places and other places are drowning
because,
uh,
the earth's equilibrium is so off.
Um,
and so I think the long term conversation is,
um,
is capitalism as a sustainable model.
And many of us know it's not.
Um,
so what does that mean?
And that I don't have the answer to,
but I have a lot of questions about,
uh,
and I think our movement often is trying to figure that out and have questions
about,
I think,
you know,
Google is such an interesting place,
right?
It's both.
Um,
it's worldwide.
It's a huge corporation.
Also will bring one of the co founders of black lives matter to talk to it's
employees.
It's like such an interesting contradiction.
Uh,
and um,
my hope is that I,
I'm not going to be able to change Google necessarily,
but I think the hope and this certain moment is to change the hearts and minds
of people who work here.
Um,
and how we make decisions about how we relate to the planet and other human
beings.
That was beautiful.
Thank you.
Um,
let me,
Oh,
there's a question.
No,
please go ahead.
I have already spoken to way more men.
Anyone wants,
they gone off.
So you mentioned about sort of the strategic goals.
So,
um,
specifically what are some of the things that sparked the movement?
Right to shy and please do anything.
Some of this violence,
do you or does it have shorter doubles either through activism or let's see or
changes to do dry and bland on some of the more egregious policing tactics,
that ridiculous use of force type of uh,
mandates.
Are there the specific goals around that?
Yeah,
actually I was just on a phone call about it before I got here talking to our
lawyers.
Um,
it's a great question because someone asked me there,
the old Time magazine asked me the other day and said,
well,
it will ever be a me too of racism.
And I was like,
well,
it's called black lives matter.
But what I think is interesting,
I think what he was trying to ask actually what was me too has been successful
at literally knocking down some of the biggest power players in Hollywood.
I mean,
people that we never thought would be sort of take it out,
you know,
taken out of Hollywood have been,
um,
whether or not they have huge pensions and they could still live their lives.
That's a whole nother question.
But symbolically what that has shown us is that sexual assault and violence is
not going to be taken lightly anymore.
And he was trying to ask her why,
how come law enforcement hasn't been,
we haven't had the same impact on law enforcement.
And what I did is I said,
well,
that's my black lives matter fault.
We've done everything we can to hold that person accountable.
But rather,
um,
we have to have a larger conversation about the people who keep law enforcement
in power,
elected officials,
um,
county board of supervisors,
uh,
state governors,
the laws,
I mean they're literally,
um,
and the us,
I think there's over 22 a piece off the peace officer bill of rights,
right?
Which literally are,
um,
a document that gives rights to the peace officer's that pretty much excludes
them from being held accountable for their acts.
California and Seattle have some of the worst police officer's bill of rights.
And so much of what we're trying to do is go state by state,
city,
by city,
county,
by county,
um,
changing those laws.
Uh,
the first experiment is going to be California because we have some of the most
egregious lots,
but also because you have some of those progressive legislators.
So can we get enough legislators to say we can't allow this to happen anymore?
Can we get enough to stick attorneys to say,
cause within a district attorney's right to prosecute an officer,
but they more often err on not.
So the work I think is that in the next phase specifically around law
enforcement,
violence is trying to change lives.
I think that we've hit it,
we've hit a road,
we have to take things to the ballot box and galvanize our movement to push new
laws for it.
And it's just a quick follow.
Yeah,
it does it.
Do you have a specific,
do you want they use a body camera as I do.
I do.
Um,
we have cell phones,
so that's one.
Um,
body cameras are millions and millions of dollars and oftentimes that
accountability,
let me flip it.
The responsibility is on the officer to turn on the body camera.
Um,
so how many times have we seen law enforcement not turn on their body camera?
Almost all the time.
And so,
um,
I think it's an interesting demand,
but if we make body cameras as the solution to ending law enforcement violence
that we've lost a long time ago,
the term terrorism has erupted because there has been some incidents,
some times at some protest where there,
you know,
then maybe filings to has occurred.
Right.
Um,
does,
do you ever come to a point where your organization just comes out there and
flat out,
you know,
dino something and say,
this is not something that we can go and sometimes you cannot be,
you know,
responsible for everybody.
Yeah.
Their protest.
Um,
but he's there in the same way where you ally with some people for the same
cause and you know,
under the name of intersectionality,
although I hate that word,
but do you,
you know,
do you do both?
Is there,
is there a time where you,
you know,
you throw the power of the network behind a cause and you followed through with
it?
I may not be necessarily under the broad umbrella of black lives matter.
And is there a time where you see some things,
I'd had a protest or even inside your own movement,
where do you go out there and you just do announce exactly.
I mean,
yes.
Um,
I think the Dallas shooting,
we'd announced immediately,
uh,
Micah Johnson.
Um,
and I talked about that in the book,
but you know,
there's never been a shooting from someone who said that they did a on a half of
black lives matter.
It's always been attributed to black lives matter.
And our movement from,
from jump has been on violent.
I mean,
that's just been clear.
In fact,
we've been calling for law enforcement up killing us.
Right?
Uh,
and I think the conversation about,
um,
you know,
violence versus a non violence is a really important political conversation.
And frankly,
um,
we're in a different time period.
You know,
the panthers wet on Sacramento steps and had guns and we would never do that
because we see the result.
Black person doesn't need a gun to get kilz.
So I think for us the most effective and safe strategy is a nonviolent strategy
in this particular moment.
Can I just ask a quick follow up to this?
So I'm mean social media,
usually whatever the Hashtag is in the family,
do you have things,
you know,
have a power of the narrative?
So if tomorrow something was going on with the movement and I wanted to check,
okay,
what's the official word from your network?
What would I go?
Oh,
that's a good question.
Um,
you mean like where on what social media pages?
Bj's or just online or,
so black lives matter.com is our website on Facebook were verified.
Um,
do not use any other Facebook profile because there's titans and then not
verified and some of them will still your money.
Um,
and on Twitter we are black lives matter,
but we're blk I'm same on Instagram and the most updated sort of like stand that
we have on something is usually going to be at our Twitter account.
I thank you for speaking.
Oh yeah,
no question about intersectionality and the labor movement.
Yeah.
Like where do they lie?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I don't think police union should be able to
bargain about whether or not they respect people's human rights.
Uh,
Ken,
the Labor movement still be an allied to black lives matter.
This is such a good question.
And these are,
you know,
I've sat with a lot of labor folks around this,
so much so that we've really challenged Labor to have law enforcement as part of
their union.
I think,
honestly,
um,
and a lot of places law enforcement is the strongest union.
Um,
they have the,
um,
the most lawyers,
they have the most money and,
um,
they have a lot of power.
So when we've talked to presidents and we've talked to,
um,
union organizers,
they're a pain in the butt and unions they are because they're the first ones to
like stop any sort of democratic process or challenge any sort of progressive
statement the union wants to put out.
Um,
but until unions,
staff and still union leadership stands up to law enforcement unions,
we're going to continue in the same cycle.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
I spoke to one of 'em,
I don't remember which,
um,
Black Panther member said this to us,
but they said that we are,
we are the first effective movement to actually challenge law enforcement to
actually,
um,
curb the community and a culture that believes law enforcement first.
Um,
and that to me is just the beginning of really trying to change the seats of
power.
Um,
but right now law enforcement is still has all the bargaining chips.
Really an earlier question you asked you what in or gives you hope,
what in politics and all three bl.
What else?
What else gives you hope in politics?
And I'm an engineer.
I'm not going to be political activists.
What can I do?
Great.
That's a great question.
Um,
okay.
Two things.
One,
I'm going to start with your last question.
What can you do?
Everybody has their lane.
Um,
I think,
um,
that,
uh,
you don't have to go out into the streets to be active,
um,
to be aware,
to challenge,
um,
awful things that happened to people.
Um,
you can,
um,
have conversations.
You can,
um,
be a part of book clubs.
You could be a part of dialogues.
I think even coming into this room is an act of solidarity and a,
uh,
a show of good faith.
Um,
we also come from families.
How are we raising our children?
How we talking to are our wives,
our husbands,
our sisters,
our brothers.
Um,
you know what I usually get the question around how can white people help?
The first thing I say is go talk to your family members.
Have those hard or challenging conversations that we often say,
oh,
I'm just going to ignore that.
Right?
Um,
I think how we're living our lives is just as important as,
uh,
if you're out in the streets being politically active.
What was your first question?
What gives you what,
when,
when pope,
um,
political hope,
right?
I'm excited about,
um,
how many people that
are running for office that are folks of color,
women of color.
Um,
I'm excited about,
um,
the conversations that are happening around political power.
Um,
I'm excited about how engaged,
you know,
my mother is,
I mean,
I've been in this work for a long time and my mother never talked about politics
and she'll like call me and purse out Trump and I don't like,
oh,
you're like,
you're feeling engaged in this moment.
Even if it's against a person.
There's something about this moment that's making people want to do more than
they've ever done before.
And uh,
and the one hand,
it's devastating to witness so many executive orders totally ripped through our
constitution.
And on the other hand,
it's brilliant to see so many people saying,
no,
I'm not going to stand for this.
Yeah.
I want to make sure,
wait,
no microphone.
No,
you go on to make sure we leave some time for a signing and for,
and not just because people are like,
no,
I have more questions.
I want to make sure we need sometimes for signing and for people to actually
kept the book.
Um,
so again,
thank you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate you taking the time.
Thank you all for [inaudible].